you want to know something about
yourself sit on your bed one night and
say what's one thing i'm doing wrong
that i know i'm doing wrong that i could
fix that i would fix you meditate on
that you'll get an answer and it won't
be one you want but it'll be the
necessary one when you're trapped some
of it's your own inadequacy what you can
do to begin with is every bloody thing
you possibly can do to put yourself in
the most virtuous and powerful
negotiating position possible wherever i
go in the world people come up to me and
they often have a pretty rough story to
relate it's an awful thing because you
see even in the revelation of their
triumph the initial depth of their
despair
so i wouldn't change that
but it's not nothing
it's certainly not just happiness
it's better than happiness but it's
almost unbearable
[Music]
quick one can you do me a favor if
you're listening to this and hit the
subscribe button the follow button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast thank you so much the
conversation
you guys have been waiting for
i say that because of the thousands and
thousands of messages i've had since i
announced that jordan peterson the man
himself
all the way from canada came here to sit
in my kitchen and have a conversation
with me
and what a conversation it was
one of the most moving moments in the
history of this podcast takes place
in this conversation
and i think the thing that people love
about jordan peterson is his unrelenting
desire to just say what he believes to
be true
not what he believes to be correct
not what people want to hear
not what people will be happy to hear
and it's because of that it's because of
his pursuit of truth
that he's managed to change millions and
millions and millions of people's lives
that is absolutely no understatement
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
jordan um first i i feel i feel like i
owe you a debt of gratitude and i want
to say thank you for the the impact
you've had on my life and i'll i'll
point at the the specific impact you've
had on my life um
i and you asked me before you start
recording why this podcast has been
successful one of the reasons is
actually something i've i've gained from
from reading and listening to your work
and that's this real commitment to
trying to be your true self and trying
to be your truth
this podcast wouldn't be successful and
i wouldn't have been successful in terms
of um pursuing myself had i not
understood the importance of truth
across all facets of life and in my
relationships which is a real pivotal
thing for me and that's fine so what's
changed in your relationships as a
consequence of that so um
i i believe it's really difficult to
truly connect with someone if you're not
speaking and being your truth and i i
wasn't i was i think i was wearing a
mask in my relationships in a context if
i didn't express how i was thinking and
feeling i was trying to be who i thought
my partner wanted me to be and at the
point when i like i let down the mask
and i started speaking my truth
unexp actually as i was departing from
the relationship the relationship got
stronger than ever before and it was
like we were never actually connected
until i was being true with her with my
feelings with what i wanted with my life
and since then i i would categorize my
relationship as being the strongest
thing i've ever seen in terms of a
romantic connection with someone and so
when you were starting to talk in your
relationship in a more truthful manner
what did that mean that you had to admit
i mean you just said that part of it was
a disconnect between who you were trying
to be and who you really were so that's
a persona issue right so you think maybe
and everyone has this proclivity to some
degree as they're deeply
self-conscious and uncertain
and so instead of allowing the person
they're with to connect with that
underlying uncertainty and inadequacy
they
act out a persona and then the problem
is is that well perhaps the person falls
in love with that persona
but
there's no real connection there it's
it's an artifice
and you know having said that
one of the things that carl jung the
great psychotherapist said about a
persona is
don't be thinking that you're better off
if you never formed one
so for jung it was a voyage from
say undifferentiated self in infancy and
so forth
through persona to authenticity because
you have to act out your ideals to some
degree right and
and and you also have to formulate a
avatar of yourself in some sense that's
a mediator between you and other people
in casual social encounters like you
don't want to walk into the bank and
have the teller tell you about his or
her day when you say how are you doing
right i mean now and then that can
happen but generally it's too much
intimacy too quickly and so you need
this this functional shell
but the problem arises when
that functional shell is all that there
is and then the real person underneath
is just desperate and
and unhappy because
nothing of what's being acted out
reflects a true underlying reality
what is the consequence the long-term
consequence of acting so many people
especially because of the world i live
in instagram and social media we kind of
build out these personas and then yeah
we almost follow the implicit
instructions that come with those
personas so that's the problem right
there is that well
that that i'm trying to get a hold of
the disney people at the moment because
i want to do a lecture series on
pinocchio because i think pinocchio is
brilliant work of art
and
if you're a puppet and an actor and
pinocchio is both at times in that movie
both a puppet and an actor
so why an actor like why is there why is
there something wrong with being an
actor well the first question is
well who sets your role
and then the second question is
who's pulling your strings
so you've put on this front that is
there to make you popular and sexy and
desirable and to mask from yourself your
own inadequacies but that's a role well
who wrote it and for what purpose
and so jung said for example that we all
acted out a myth and whether we knew it
or not and you know maybe you're acting
out a tragedy
maybe you're acting out narcissus
you don't know
because you've put that you've put that
on yourself in an attempt in some ways
to deliver to people what they want or
more accurately to look as though you're
delivering to people what they want and
it's not nothing to do that right
because at least you're attempting in
some sense to adapt to the social world
someone who's really infantile and
dependent someone who's never left home
part of their problem is that they
haven't crafted a persona
so you don't want to denigrate it
entirely but it's no substitute for the
real thing and it turns out that
not only is what we want from each other
the real thing
but that's also the adventure of your
life and so if you aren't
truthful and that means unfortunately
especially at the beginning when you
start to be truthful it means
deeply coming to terms with your
inadequacies in humility so it's very
painful without that you don't have the
adventure of your life you have the role
that has been
that you've
acquiesced to and that'll take all the
meaning out of your life
the adventure of your life
you say imagine who you could be and
then aim single-mindedly at that um
i encounter these young people who
appear to know who they could be or they
they've imagined who they could be but
for whatever reason they seem to choose
the certain misery of their current
situation the job that's sucking their
soul out or that relationship um over
the uncertainty they'll encounter as
they go on the adventure of their life
so what would i say to these young
people who always say to me steve i i
want to do this but you can see them
stifled by fear because it's like yeah
well it's like make a plan man it's so
when i was
doing my clinical work which i i did a
lot of career
work with my clients both at a beginner
level i would say like really a beginner
level with people who had no employment
whatsoever no history of employment who
are under-educated and who lacked every
skill you could possibly imagine these
are people who were really in dire
straits up to people who were operating
at the top of their profession but who
could still strategize forward and so
for example let's say you're at a dead
end in your job
okay so
i don't find my work meaningful all
right so that's a problem statement it's
like well why not i find the work i do
repetitive and boring and without spirit
i have a bad relationship or a neutral
relationship with my boss who doesn't
know who i am
i have problems with co-workers all of
that needs to be differentiated right
and analyzed in detail so
we might say for example let's say you
believe that you're undervalued at work
and maybe you are
what you need to do is you have
something to say and
we would have to figure out what it is
that you have to say but it would be
some variant of i'm bringing more value
to the table than i'm being compensated
for
and that's demoralizing me and it's also
not good for you you being my boss
because if i'm actually more valuable
than is being recognized then the fact
that you're not valuing me properly
means that i will become demoralized i
won't work properly and you won't get
the best out of me so it's bad for both
of us and
if your boss is in principle not
amenable to such a discussion then what
you should seriously consider doing is
finding another job
okay so let's say we're going to set you
up for this okay this isn't like next
week's enterprise man this is your life
so the first thing i would ask is well
do you have your resume or cv in order
well i haven't typed it up for three
years
well what do you think about bringing it
up well i'm pretty nervous about that
because there's some holes in it and you
know i didn't do so well in college and
i'm kind of embarrassed about my resume
it's like
okay bring it in let's go through it
let's let's let's at least update it
let's look where the holes are let's
look at where the inadequacies are as
far as you're concerned right this isn't
my judgment it's your judgment let's
walk through those judgments and see if
they're warranted because maybe you're
just too guilty and ashamed and
self-conscious and anxious and you're
not
you're looking at your resume more
critically than someone else would and
maybe there's some holes that you need
to rectify you know you're you're at you
you were two courses away from your ba
and you dropped out or something like
that
well
maybe we need six months to address that
and at least even if you can't be fully
educated you could be taking some
courses online and so when you went to a
new job interview and they said what
about this hole you'd say well i
i
came to terms with that six months ago
and in an effort to rectify it i'm
taking the following courses and here's
my plan for completion that's a really
good answer
and anyone with any sense who's
interviewing
will accept that as an indication that
although you're not perfect and who is
that you have a good plan and that
you've thought it through like that's
the kind of answer that
in all likelihood will cement your
candidacy for the position okay so now
you're gonna go to your boss well you
have to have your cv and your resume in
order and you have to be able to stand
on it solidly and
which at least means that you're
prepared to address the inadequacies
in a credible realistic believable and
truthful manner
all right now what you do is apply for
like 10 jobs
you don't have to take them
but maybe you have to go to an interview
or two or three or four and maybe
there's a bunch of opportunities out
there for you that you didn't even know
about
and maybe someone offers you a job
and so now now you can go to your boss
and say
here's the situation i'm in here at work
um here's my evaluation of the problems
in relationship to me here's what i
could do for you if you gave me a 40
raise and the opportunity to progress
but i'd like to see a plan for that and
um i've been looking for other
opportunities before conducting this
discussion and i have some
right well then if your boss treats you
with contempt at that point and doesn't
listen then perhaps he or she is a
little more narcissistic than might be
optimal and it's time to find a new job
but this isn't something you do
trivially and
so when you're doubtful say you're
trapped
you ask yourself well
why am i trapped
and that's a hard question right because
some of it's your own
inadequacy a lot of it and all of the
part of it that you can deal with is
your own inadequacy
so even if it's unfair you know even if
you're hemmed in for any number of
reasons
inappropriate like ethnically predicated
oppression let's say or maybe you live
it you're in a workplace that really is
sexist in some fundamental sense
well
that's not good it's not just it's not
fair it's it's not meritorious all of
those things man maybe you shouldn't be
there but
what you can do to begin with is every
bloody thing you possibly can do to put
yourself in the most
virtuous and powerful negotiating
position possible
and you have to think like a snake in
some sense
to do that you got to get the details
right you have to be prepared to bite
and and you have to have your eyes on
the prize so to speak and people aren't
taught this sort of thing ever really
they're not taught how to negotiate
they're not taught how to goal set
they're not taught how to conceptualize
appropriate success in some broad sense
in some sense that's what the humanities
are supposed to teach people
so
on that point of understanding my
inadequacies or someone's inadequacies i
really believe um that it's really
difficult to undergo self-development if
you don't have self-awareness and i was
i was really trying to understand from
your writings how someone is to build
their self-awareness it's almost like
the unknown unknown if you don't have it
how do you build the thing i know a good
exercise for that
it's like a prayer in some sense in fact
i would say it's proper prayer if you
want to know something about yourself
sit on your bed one night and say to
yourself you got to mean this like you
got to be desperate this is no game this
it's like
my life is not everything i want it to
be and perhaps it's not everything that
i need it to be and by need i mean my
life is so unbearable that
the suffering that's attended upon that
is make me nihilistic cynical bitter
resentful homicidal
in the unable to have a good
relationship pro
prone to punish people for their virtues
because of my jealousy
uh
driving the proclivity to see evil
everywhere except within my own heart
like these are problems man
and
you ask yourself you sit on the bed and
say okay man i'm ready to
learn something like what
what's one thing i'm doing wrong
that i know i'm doing wrong that i could
fix
that i would fix it's like
you meditate on that you'll get an
answer
and it won't be one you want but it'll
be the necessary one
you know and it's often
something that will point you to small
things
so carl jung said people in the modern
world don't see god because they don't
look low enough
and so imagine you're in your messy
bedroom
you know and you're sitting on the edge
of the bed trying to have an honest
dialogue with yourself and the little
voice says
you know it's pretty disgusting in here
and you think well i'm way above such
trivial niceties as organizing my room
it's like well that's pride that's
arrogance
if you're above
organizing what's actually yours
how in the world are you ever going to
organize anything else and so you get on
your knees and you think well it's time
to
you know
take a brush to the toilet
and maybe that's where you start
and so and that works like that works
you start making those micro
improvements like real micro
improvements real on the ground actual
micro improvements to things you know
that are wrong
you'll improve unbelievably rapidly
what you're talking about there sounds
to me a lot like um
an over
dose of arrogance and also the need for
humility do you think the western world
suffers from arrogance because of our
our relative um
privilege and luxury that we kind of
overlook of course well that's a
temptation right i mean when the when
the left radical lefty types go after
people for their unearned privilege they
have a point
now
the point is
the existentialists called it throneness
which is enough
that's a high dagarian term
and throneness is the fact that
we kind of experience life as if we're
tossed into it thrown into it you know
you're you're male and not female you're
you're hindu and not christian
you're tall and not short you have an
arbitrary range of talents and an
arbitrary range of limitations none of
which in some sense you chose
it's the cards you're dealt
now some of those are cards of privilege
you know maybe you're born intelligent
maybe you're born symmetrical maybe
you're born healthy
maybe you're born into a culture where
it's much easier not to be absolutely
deprived maybe your parents are rich
and so
all of that in some sense is unearned
now along with that comes
a good dose of existential guilt
because at the same time and this is
true for anyone
regardless of their cultural background
the
ground we walk on is soaked in the blood
of historical atrocity
and so that's on you
because
you know people think well who's the
nazi well it's the fascist or it's the
or who's the radical communist it's the
radical left-wing ideologue and the
fundamental truth of the matter is
that's best dealt with as a spiritual
matter is
the adversary is within
really
most profoundly and so you have to take
the responsibility for that historical
atrocity onto yourself i was talking to
guy ritchie this week about his movie
king arthur it's quite an interesting
movie in many ways
and when arthur who could be the hero
takes the sword
he's so overcome by visions of his
murderous uncle that he can't pick up
the weapon well
think about that now you have weapons at
your disposal
but they've been used by your murderous
uncle
how dare you wield them
and the answer is maybe it's easy just
to leave the sword on the ground because
you do want to be responsible for
atrocities going forward and don't think
you couldn't be and don't think you
might not enjoy it
and so
the way you pay for your privilege is
with your virtue
i mean that most particularly you have
these opportunities and this existential
guilt and the way you expiate that and
atone is by doing your best to live the
best possible life you can manage to
speak the truth to treat people with
respect to abide by the principles of
the dignity of the individual and to put
your house in order
and that's how you pay for your unearned
privilege all of us
and we all have our privileges and our
and our curses you know all of us have
that that's why it's not useful to be
envious of people
you know you see some you're a young man
you see someone drive by in a ferrari
with a blonde and you think my god he's
got everything and you know the woman in
the car is a prostitute who's got a
cocaine addiction and her her life is
just one catastrophe after another and
he's had to lie and cheat his way into
this position and he's afraid that
everything's going to come crashing down
on him and that's what you're jealous of
and it's just not that
profound
you don't want someone else's fate man
your fate's enough and your adventure's
enough it's plenty it's more than you
can ever fully realize
and so that's also part of the reason
that we all believe that the individual
has some intrinsic dignity it's don't be
so sure that your position and your room
is so damn trivial it might be your
attitude towards it that's trivial and
if you're in dire straits and dire
circumstances
just look at how much opportunity you
have to make things better
so not that it's easy i you don't even
want it to be easy
you know so
on that point of you don't want it to be
easy i've really contended with this
idea of struggle and chaos in my life
and the role it plays and once upon a
time i thought i was trying to
rid my life of chaos and struggle i
thought that's why i was trying to get
rich and get the ferrari and the blonde
i thought that would create a life free
of free of struggle but then i looked at
some studies and i heard about this
thing called gold medal depression when
olympians come back from the olympics
and they've lost orientation and then
the day when someone offered to buy my
company for a
eight nine a nine figure number and it
filled me with this emptiness and this
dread and i i tried to understand the
role that struggle would would have to
play for me to be a fulfilled human
being for the rest of my life
yeah well that the observation with
regard to your company that's a that's a
great observation i mean we're built to
walk uphill and
when you
reach the pinnacle of the hill you want
to stop and appreciate the vision but
the next thing you want is a higher hill
in the distance because
it's the uphill climb that it's it's
from the uphill climb that we derive our
value and i mean this technically so
almost all the positive emotion we feel
especially the the
the emotion that fills us with
enthusiasm and that's to be filled with
the spirit of god by the way because
that's what enthusiasm means
that's
experienced in relationship to a goal
and so in some sense and this is part of
the religious enterprise you want a goal
that you can never attain
right so you can always move closer to
the goal that recedes as you move
towards it you think well that's
frustrating it's like sisyphus pushing
the rock uphill but it's not because as
you pursue that goal you put yourself
together and your life does get better
and richer and more abundant that's why
the highest levels of virtue and goal
are in some sense transcendent
you want them to be above everything
you're doing so you can continually move
towards something that's more sublime
and better
that's what you are you're here to live
not to
not to sleep
and the problem with the vision of my
ties on the beach is that well first of
all that's an envision that's a vision
of of drug-induced
unconsciousness second it's only going
to work for about a week third you're
going to be a laughingstock in a month
and depressed and aimless
and and goalless it's no that's not it's
it's you want a horizon of ever
expanding possibility and so it does
happen to people as they because they've
staked their soul
on the attainment of an instrumental
goal and it can be a pretty high order
goal it was in your case but then you
think
well i've now i'm there now what
well the answer can't be
well i'm going to live in the lap of
luxury and never have to leave the fa
what do you want to be a giant infant
with a gold
with a gold bottle you never have to do
anything but lay in your back and suck
it's like
well you see the problem with that as a
as a
as a conceptualization it's no you want
to be
like an active warrior moving up hill
with your sword in hand and
that's that's dynamic that's exciting
and that's why so many young men
disappear into video games it's that's
all acted out in the video game
so they have to act that out in their
own life not that i despise video games
because i don't but they're not a
substitute for life they might be good
training under some conditions for life
so
one of the things i was also really
really keen to ask you was about the the
what's happened in the world over the
last two years one of the shifts we've
seen in the business world is this move
to remote working and i
hate it and i hate it for a variety of
reasons because i feel like there's very
few institutions in
my life where i have a chance to
meaningfully connect with with people
dating has become screens socializing
has become screens
and the office the institution of the
office in my life was one of the places
especially as a younger man where i got
to meet pretty much 90 percent of my
current best friends and also
partners and and i really worry about um
sitting behind a zoom
doing my work um for for the re for the
next 10 years what is your take on
remote working
well
i like it and i don't like it i i think
it's very difficult for us to understand
our embodied environments well enough to
duplicate them in a healthy and
comprehensive
manner
in the virtual world because we just
don't understand what it is that we're
doing when we actually do things rather
than represent them so for example i've
thought a lot about
online university okay so then you can
imagine
well you can certainly imagine online
lecture courses
and you could say well the fact that
they can be delivered on a large scale
very inexpensively is a virtue you can
bring the knowledge to a very large
number of people at a low cost so why
not do that and so that's half the
university and then you could say well
imagine that you generated the system of
universal tests which is possibility and
that means you could bring accreditation
to everyone at a low cost as well and
that's that universities online but that
presumes that you know what the
university is and you don't because well
here's some other things the university
is
an excuse for young a credible excuse
that's socially sanctioned for young
people who have not yet established a
career goal to adopt an identity of
upward striving for four years away from
their parents while they meet a new
group of friends
like that might be 90 of the university
for all we know because it's certainly
for me for example
when i went to college
i i left home when i was 17 and i left a
sm this small town i had grown up in and
in many ways i left the peers that i had
been associating with now a couple of
them came to college with me so i had a
toehold there but i made an entirely
different group of friends and they were
friends whose goals were quite radically
different from the friends that i let's
say
in some sense left behind
well
the reformulation of my peer network
might have been the most important part
of of the first part of my education now
i was fortunate at this place it was
called grand prairie college i had
seven professors
seven which is really good who really
loved to teach and so i also learned a
lot in the formal sense but while i was
doing that i was also negotiating well
how much partying do you actually do
because zero isn't the right amount
but every goddamn night till three in
the morning isn't the right amount
either because you have to balance that
in some sense with practicality and
upward striving and so and and how do i
live with other people my roommate so i
had one roommate who's a really good
friend of mine still and he walked a
thousand miles with me this year when i
was ill literally
so
um i really liked living with him
because he was a tough guy worked in
lead smelters and
he was a cowboy and he was a tough guy
four years older than me about three
years older than me had come back to
school after bouncing around through
these like tough working-class
occupations and he had his feet on the
ground in lots of ways and
i really liked him as a roommate because
i'd buy some groceries and
then he'd buy some groceries or i'd make
dinner and he'd make breakfast and none
of that was ever explicitly
negotiated
he was just very aware of this
reciprocal it's reciprocal altruism
technically he was very
good at
we were both good at tracking our mutual
obligations and fulfilling them so we
had a very peaceful relationship i
lived with him for a year and and then a
little bit in different at different
times and in different places and i i
learned to
live with a whole variety of roommates
had many roommates uh
we had a kind of a frat house in the
first college i went to and i think
anywhere from six to twenty people lived
there depending on the week you know it
was really it was ridiculous it was way
too much fun
and that was also a problem but
when i look back on that time in my life
i certainly can't reduce the educational
experience to
virtual classes and virtual tests that's
maybe that's 10 of it and we don't know
how to replicate those
environments that are so formative
especially in in their everydayness you
know because you live with your
roommates
that's a 24-hour thing and so
the problem with virtualization is that
we don't understand our environments
well enough
to be certain that we're not excluding
something vital when we concentrate only
on what we think
conceptually is important
now
i meet with my son pretty regularly for
a project we're working on which is an
app that will teach people to write well
they write and use it so we're quite
excited about this but i meet with him
virtually once a week and it's actually
very efficient
he's on the screen we can see our
project in front of us we can do mutual
editing of some of the of the uh
underlying material educational material
there's a real place for it and
i have a cottage up north in toronto
where we've set up a studio like your
studio here all the wars isn't quite as
impressive
but i can
have an
interview and discussion with anyone
anywhere in the world even in a foreign
language and that's like unbelievably
remarkable but but
that doesn't mean that
we know how to virtualize reality or
that we should flee into it right and
these new technologies they're
unbelievably radical and they're very
hard to master and so we all have to be
careful and try to keep our feet on the
ground to some degree when we're using
them so for example now i've really only
figured this out in the last three
months
i get up and i i do a series of
exercises that my wife taught me that
are based in the kundalini yoga
tradition that's real helpful
flexibility and breathing exercises that
reduces my anxiety during the day i
would say about 25
and then i try to
reserve some time either for writing
or i'm working on a number of artistic
projects and so i'm going to do one or
those
for a couple hours in the morning and
then maybe a walk or something with my
wife and breakfast i have breakfast
during all this
and then i can turn to
the sort of connected world email and
the podcasts and so forth and
so there's this balance between privacy
introverted privacy let's say
and disconnect from everyone
except for my wife and then
contemplated
reconnection with the virtual world that
seems to be working out pretty well
and you want to get a balance of that
that's actually to use a terrible cliche
sustainable right so you want to hit
your projects hard but you have to
leave in that
not with entertainment but with culture
because those are not the same thing
entertainment is an approximation to
culture
and you need to live in that with
culture that's beauty and drama and art
and all of that and then with
intimate relationships and friendships
and
well it's very difficult to get the
balance of all that correct and
it's very difficult to do that virtually
so but i certainly wouldn't forego the
technology and neither would the rest of
us it's like people complain about their
phones but they carry them with them
everywhere they go and i'm not cynical
about that the phone it's not a phone
god only knows what it is
but it's definitely not a phone
and so
it's not surprising that since it just
appeared and it's so insanely powerful
that we don't know what to do with it
and that might even wreck everything
like god only knows twitter itself could
bring civilization to a halt we we don't
know how to manage the unintended
consequences of our technological
prowess
and that's exactly it that's it's the we
invent technology often it seems for
efficiency or to increase productivity
and it's almost impossible because of
that ignorance to what the um the
unintended consequences might be
to predict them ahead of time so we
optimize essential doctrine of
conservative political philosophy right
is
beware of unintended consequences it's
like oh no this thing will just do what
i want it to do with nothing else it's
like
no even marx knew that wasn't true marx
marx developed a concept the concept of
alienation you know we get alienated
from the products of our effort
that's part of the reason he didn't like
factories
and and fair enough you know because
factory work which is repetitive
in some sense destroys our artisanal
relationship with what we produce now
the problem with marx's analysis is that
yeah but it's pretty damn efficient and
it lifts people out of absolute poverty
really quickly so
but that doesn't mean that and
existential philosophers after marx
developed the concept of alienation to
quite a high degree
and technology does alienate us
because of its artificiality and its and
its its coldness and its mechanistic
nature all of that and
well we have to contend with that wisely
and
then you ask well how do you contend
with things wisely and i would say well
don't pollute your thoughts with deceit
you compromise your own wisdom
how are you going to make intelligent
not intelligent decisions wise decisions
that's why you shouldn't lies like
you're warping the mechanism that
orients you in the world do you really
want to do that
this is a brutal world man and i've seen
this in my clinical practice
people whose houses are built on
foundations of sand and the wind starts
to blow and the floods start to rise and
they are in such trouble
such trouble
if you're lucky
and something terrible comes your way
and you're
reasonably honest and your relationships
are in good order
maybe you won't end up in hell
and and i mean hell i don't mean death
there's lots of situations you can get
yourself in where death would be far
preferable to what you're going through
so
you you need to be afraid of that it's
like don't lie i in my clinical practice
in 20 years
working with every sort of person you
could imagine
i never ever saw anyone get away with
anything even once
so
yeah we're all subject not least to the
judgment of our own conscience try to
escape from that
because
no one can escape from that
quick one
i can't talk about huel enough in my
life especially right now and it's
really interesting because what we tend
to see at this time of year
is the first thing that goes is our diet
quickly followed by our fitness and we
see that in the data across multiple
surveys people in the fourth quarter of
the year start indulging a little bit
more which is totally fine and they
start exercising a little bit less which
is totally fine however a really useful
crutch during this period where the
seasons have changed and we're starting
to behave a little bit differently is
making sure your fridge is stocked with
things that are nutritionally complete
healthy and that are going to be
convenient for you to consume without
compromising your health and that is
where ladies and gentlemen huel comes in
and they now have four brand new flavors
they have the salted caramel flavor
absolutely love they have the cinnamon
swirl flavor the number one new flavor
in my opinion which is really surprising
iced coffee caramel and they have the
strawberries in cream flavor if you're
going to try any of the new flavors
please do try the cinnamon swirl and let
me know what you think it's an
absolutely unexpected champion of the
new flavors
over the last two years the world has
gone through this this pandemic for a
lot of people this is the first time
um especially for a certain generation
this is the first time they've
experienced such unpredictable tectonic
um
uh
destabilization in their lives like we i
didn't even believe society was
something that could close i didn't
believe the tech there was i didn't even
know there was tectonic plates under my
business that could shut down my
business right and also in your
over the last two years you've undergone
some really you know i don't even know
what the right adjective is to use to to
technically not bad we'll go with
tectonic then sure um tectonic you know
unfortunate um
challenges i'll say in your life but
also you know with your family what are
the lessons we learn from
the pandemic and from that type of
tectonic suffering about what actually
matters in our lives well we'll see with
regard to the pandemic because
although in some sense it is in some
ways over our reaction to it is by no
means over
and part of the reason that we
overreacted i would say so precipitously
to it is that we were unprepared for
such things in our naivety and then we
rushed to imitate a totalitarian society
in the immediate aftermath of the
pandemic
emergence and that's something that
everybody should think about a lot
and we're not done with all that
totalitarian nonsense yet a lot of
that's driven by
well fear and naivety i mean 50 percent
of democrats in the united states
believe you have a 50 chance of being
hospitalized with covet and 25 of
republicans believe the same thing and
you can point a finger at people and
laugh at their ignorance but you should
really ask well why is this overestimate
of that magnitude and what does that
mean in relationship to policy and i've
had conversations with people
advising at the highest level of
government in particularly in canada
who've told me flat out
and they're very reliable sources
that
none of the covid policy for the last
year was driven by reliance on science
it's all opinion poll
and that's really pernicious because
well who's asking the questions and how
did they set up the answer and who's
answering and in what emotional state
and so to what degree are we led by
considerations of short-term
propitiation of unwarranted fear well
that's no way for free people to live it
certainly won't work in the long run
we're already seeing
tremendous supply chain disruptions and
likely the emergence of an inflationary
pressure that we haven't experienced
since the 1970s in the aftermath
aftermath of the oil shocks and none of
that has sorted itself out yet
i believe that we will conclude that our
response to the pandemic
caused more death and misery than the
pandemic itself
and we have no end game in sight another
thing i asked
the people that i was speaking with it's
like
when is this over
well we don't know well what would over
look like
well we don't really know and now what
you see is this
insistence on about a monthly basis that
a new and radically different variant
has emerged and
this virus viruses mutate all the time
but this virus particularly mutates and
there are small mutations and
medium-sized mutations numbers let's say
and also effect and
and larger scale mutations
when is that a variant well how about
whenever it's convenient for the
pharmaceutical companies think well
that's cynical it's is it now the
biggest lawsuits in the history of the
american judicial system have been
levied against the largest
pharmaceutical companies on a regular
basis for the last 20 years
and since wynn
have has it been a proposition of the
political left that
pharmaceutical companies necessarily
have our best interests in mind now i'm
not particularly cynical about
pharmaceutical companies i think they
have a hard job both in terms of
research and development and marketing
and sales and they're going to do what
they can to market and sell
but
that doesn't mean that they are now to
be the arbiters of all public policy
because our politicians are too cowardly
and incompetent to do anything but
devolve their responsibilities to
so-called experts domain experts
politics is not public health
that's medicine
politics is
the art of
analyzing the entire situation and
charting a course forward all things
considered
and for politicians to trot out the
experts and say follow the science just
means that they've abdicated their own
responsibilities and i think it's
appalling
i mean i'm not convinced that the
evidence that masks work is
scientifically credible it's certainly
at least doubtful and that's just masks
i read a paper the other day suggesting
that
to prevent the transmission of one case
of covit you have to lock down a
thousand people
like how is that
justifiable
especially given that the mortality rate
of covet is actually quite low unless
you have a pre-existent health problem
particularly obesity and although old
age also qualifies as it does for most
diseases but not all
and with regards to let's say the issue
of child vaccination is like children
have an unbelievably tiny chance of
dying from covid i don't think there's
any scientific
justification for immunizing children
under 12.
now at least it's debatable and i'm not
a domain expert although i'm a decent
scientist and i know how to read the
research material
and
so
well we'll see what we have to learn
from these tectonic shifts underneath
and you know you might ask yourself well
was that a tectonic shift
in
dire physical necessity because the
covet virus was genuinely so dangerous
or was it an indication tectonically of
our absolute inadequacy in the face of
even a moderate existential challenge
and maybe it's a little column a and a
little column b you know
so
i have to ask the question
if if we were to make
your jordan peterson the president of
the world and these were your decisions
to make do you know what you would have
done
um
differently or in response to this virus
emerging in wuhan i would say well thank
you for the offer but i declined the
position and the reason i would say that
is because i think the right solution to
the most serious problems is to be found
at the level of the individual
so i don't think
if i wanted to pursue what i regarded as
the ultimate goal i the ultimate goal
for me is the encouragement of the
individual and that's not a
that's not essentially a political
enterprise it's essentially a
theological enterprise and politics has
to be subordinate to that and so i've
debated throughout the entire course of
my life
whether i would
adopt a political career it was my
initial ambition when i was very young
14 i would say
but when push came to shove at every
decision point in my life if i had to
choose between
working on the encouragement of the
individual
and pursuing a or pursuing a political
career
i always chose the
the former
and that's happened every time the
decision has come up
i've been approached by people in canada
to
involve myself more deeply in a
practical role
um and also publicly as a political
figure but
i'd rather do what i'm doing
i'm in contact with people working
politically all the time
both on the
people in the middle people on the right
people on the left i'm agnostic about
that because i know full well that
conservatives have something to say and
left-leaning liberals have something to
say that's basically predicated to some
degree on their temperament so
conservatives tend to be more
conscientious so that's
orderly and industrious dutiful
patriotic
willing to make and keep verbal
contracts reliable
capable of implementation at the level
of detail that's kind of conservative
virtues there but they tend to be lower
in creativity openness to experience
they don't think is divergently
and their
conscientiousness tends to constrain
their creativity
whereas the liberal types they're high
in openness to experience that's the
creativity dimension but they tend to be
lower in conscientiousness particularly
orderliness and so
what that means is
those with a liberal temperament tend to
be creative slash entrepreneurs and
those with a conservative temperament
tend to be managerial administrative
that doesn't mean they can't run
businesses well you want a conservative
person to run your business you might
want a more liberal person to
pepper you with
off-the-wall ideas you know and then if
you're going to run an enterprise
business or a society
there has to be a continual dialogue
between people of different temperaments
so that we can keep the ship of state
let's say tracking to an ever-moving
destination that's why free speech is so
necessary it's not another right it's
the right
so because none of us know what's going
on
in the final analysis because the future
is different than the past really
we have to talk about what to do all the
time
because even if we made wise decisions
in the past that doesn't mean that we
can
mindlessly replicate those decisions
right now in the present to deal with a
changing future
so i want to help
encourage people to become the sort of
people who can engage in that free
dialogue and i think that's the best way
forward especially as we all become more
technologically powerful it's like
you better be smart enough to use your
iphone
and that's pretty damn smart let's say
wise because that's no trivial gadget
and if you're not careful with it it
will turn on you
will build authoritarian
presumptions into our artificial
intelligence systems for example
and then look the hell out
so if you're going to have
a hydrogen bomb
you better be wise enough to wield it
on that point of the encouragement of
the individual we all have people in our
lives that we want to encourage
we hope yeah we hope right and um
we sometimes fall foul of trying to
force our own bias our own intention for
them on them what is the best way if
i've got a friend in my life or a you
know partner that i want to encourage to
come out of their place of despair into
a better place how do i effectively do
that without overpowering them or
stifling them or making them feel
inadequate which is sometimes the
consequence of trying to change someone
you love
well
example's good
but then i would say disabuse yourself
of the notion that you know what is best
for this person
you don't not only do you not know you
actually don't want that responsibility
for two reasons
let's say they do what you say
and something good happens to them
well whose victory is that
yours are theirs and if it's yours did
you just steal it
and then let's say they fail
following your advice well they
pay the price for that
and you can skip away merrily and say
well i should have spoke more carefully
it's like you don't mess about with
people's destiny you do not know where
they're headed now having said that
you do what you're doing in this
interview in this podcast
you ask people questions
real questions you know
like how are you feeling
i'm not doing so good today well
you know
what's up what's going on
and you can't think well i'm going to
ask questions to lead this person in a
particular direction because that's the
same game the same instrumental game you
have to see
what it is that you want to know because
see this when people ask me questions
after my lectures you know now now and
then
or during a q a now and then people get
up and they'll ask a real question it's
part of the ongoing dialogue something
struck them they stand up there's
something they really want to know it's
an honest question and that goes real
well but
not infrequently someone stands up with
a little prepared speech that's packaged
as a question so i get this from
christian traditionalists fairly
frequently they get up and they ask me
about my religious convictions but
really what they want to do is corner me
into admitting that i should accept
jesus christ as my savior and and join a
particular let's say
denomination it's not a question
it's just a manipulation
and so
your questions like your statements your
questions should be honest and
if you ask people questions and you
really listen
they will untangle themselves
and that's partly why people love to be
attended to you know
like
if i meet people on the street you know
i ask them their name
they're all usually flustered when they
come up to me they don't really want to
interrupt me and then they're flustered
and the first thing i do is shake their
hand and ask them their name and i
listen you know not that good at
remembering names but
i listen to it and and they know how to
say their name and so it kind of settles
them down and then it sort of marks them
out as a person against the background
eh
and then if i pay attention to them and
listen they will tell me something in
like 10 seconds that i need to know
because they're they have something to
say you know
and then if you listen people tell you
what they have to say and then you get
wise because you collect all that
and so you want to help someone
well first of all you decide that
you're aiming towards help right
and and that you do that in the spirit
of ignorance this is what every good
clinician learns is i don't know where
you're headed i don't know what's wrong
with you
this is a hard problem man it's like
what's your problem
i don't know what your problem is
so let's find that out first and then
let's find out
one thing you can ask people this is
actually useful in an argument with
someone you love they're they're upset
with you
what are your preconditions for
satisfaction
now i wouldn't state it like that it's
like
if i could give you what you wanted
right now in the context of this
argument and i wasn't doing it in a
manipulative way
what is it that i would have to say or
do that would in principle satisfy you
and that's a hard question you know and
the person might say well i think you
should apologize and about this and you
know and then i will say
what words should i use
and they'll say well if you loved me
you'd know and i would say no i'm stupid
and ignorant and i don't know what the
right words are to satisfy you so why
don't you give me a hand with that and
all utter them inelegantly and awkwardly
in a good faith demonstration of my
commitment to peace and that won't be so
good because maybe it would have been
better if i came up with it myself but
maybe next time i can do slightly better
and that works it it
requires the person who's after you
to think through
the question even of
whether there's anything that could be
said or done that would satisfy them and
if the answer to that is no well
probably the relationship is over
but certainly
the person that they're accusing has
been put in an absolutely impossible
position
but usually
almost inevitably
if the person meditates on it for a bit
there is something that would satisfy
them that can be negotiated as long as
they're willing to give you the
opportunity to do it
you know stupidly and badly
so
listening man
jimmy carr i talked to jimmy carr two
weeks ago the famous comedian yeah it
was real interesting
um he said comedy is the most dialogical
of
of the entertainment forms and i thought
well what do you mean by that because
you're just talk
it's a monologue right now i do
monologues but i pay attention to the
audience right i'm always talking to
individual people in the audience and
watching their reactions and listening
to the audience as a whole so even
though it's a lecture let's say or a
talk
i'm watching the audience and responding
so we're in a kind of dance well carr
pointed out that comedians before they
hit the road and this is virtually in
invariably the case
they have their new routines so they're
they're they're corpus of potentially
funny jokes
and then they do 200 shows in front of
small audiences
and
the audience either laughs or doesn't
and if you're listening you collect all
the jokes that people laugh at if you do
that 200 times you have nothing but
hilarious material
but you listened
and then you can go out on the road and
that was very interesting to me because
humor is a mysterious
phenomenon experientially and
conceptually and it's sort of
precognitive and instinctual but it's
also extremely sophisticated then
there's an element of transcendence
about it right because you can laugh at
yourself and that's in some sense the
highest form of humor
and so it's so interesting that we can
criticize and elevate ourselves
at the same time and that we find that
intensely pleasurable
and so a good comedian collects ways to
do that shares them with the audience
and he's listening and so if you want to
help someone
the best way to help someone is not to
give them advice
but to listen to them
so
i had a guest actually come on this
podcast before jimmy carr jimmy car was
on two weeks ago and we had a great
conversation about um happiness and the
nature of happiness and the guest before
jimmy carr wrote in my diary which is a
tradition we have now where all the
guests that come on write a question for
the next guest so there is a question
there for you but the guest wrote a
question um which changed his life which
is um are you happy and i from reading
your work and understanding your
position on happiness and not being the
thing to aim for which really struck me
because i thought you know
i thought life was the north star of our
lives was to try and be happy i guess my
question is
what i was going to ask you that
question aim to be good and pray for
happiness
so the question i was going to is pretty
much that is what is a better question
for me to ask you if i'm checking in on
you because we asked that question with
good intentions are you happy what's a
better question for me to ask jordan
peterson
how are you doing how are you doing hmm
how are you doing
brilliantly and terribly
that's
you know when you listen to a profound
piece of music
one that sort of spans the whole
emotional experience
it's not happy
happy is elevator music and
probably you just shouldn't listen to
that at all
right and and you think why well
it's harmless it's trickly it's
sweet
simple it lacks depth it's shallow
that's a problem
it doesn't have that deep sense of awe
and horror i would say
that is characteristic of the best of
all music
you know you listen to some mis simple
music so-called hank williams is a good
example you know the blues cowboy from
the 50s who died of alcoholism when he
was 27 and whose voice sounds like an 80
year old man
simple melody you know but
there's nothing simple in the song and
and in the voice
it's deep you know it's like the blues
is it's like black blues in the states
from the 20s and this was certainly
influenced by that tradition
there's this
admission of a deep suffering
at the same time as
you get the
beautiful
transcendence of the music
and that's meaning you know
that's
awful in the most fundamental sense but
you need an antidote to suffering and
it has to be deep and no one deep moves
you tectonically and it's not a trivial
thing
and but that's better than happiness
and maybe if you're lucky well you're
pursuing that and while you're immersed
in it you get to be happy and and you
should fall on your knees and be
grateful for that when it happens you
know it's a gift it really is a gift
and it comes upon you unexpectedly your
happiness you know
but
you aim to climb up hill to the highest
peak you can possibly envision
and that's
that's better than happiness
why did you include terribly
well for example now when i go
wherever i go in the world people come
up to me and they're usually
i wouldn't say they're happy to see me
they're often in tears
you know
and they often have a pretty rough story
to relate you know they were suicidal or
nihilistic or homicidal or
trapped
desperate
you know and they tell me that real fast
and then they say i've overcome that to
a large degree and thank you for that
and
and you think well that's really
something to
have that happen over and over
in some ways you might think well how
could anything better possibly happen to
you and have people come up to you all
over the world strangers and open
themselves up like that like their old
friends so quickly
but
at the same time it's an awful thing
because you see
even in the revelation of their triumph
the initial depth of their despair
so i wouldn't change that
but it's not nothing
and it's certainly not just happiness
it's better than happiness but it's
almost unbearable
god tears again
it's been quite a two weeks in the uk
it's been amazing
it's been amazing such a great country
this country
such a profound place and
it was so wonderful to see
cambridge and oxford and
to be welcomed by the students and
i saw the queues around the block and
the the reaction you got i watched the
talk in cambridge and
um it was so wonderful to see because it
you know i know that you don't do what
you do for credit that kind of seems to
be
the you know the antithesis of the
pursuing your truth and doing it
in the cause of truth but um it was so
wonderful to see someone that i know has
had such a profound impact on so many be
received in such a way we have a closing
tradition okay one of the you know i
don't do this but one of the really
great ceos in our country young guys
bought a multi-billion dollar company
really great guy sat here yesterday and
i actually told him for the first time
who he was writing the question for and
i couldn't believe his face oh my god
that's the one person i want to have
dinner with this is probably the most
successful young person in our country
and he was and so he knew who he was
writing the question for so the question
that the previous guest wrote is for you
is
why do you do
what you do
to see what will happen
some programs you you cannot predict
right you cannot predict how they're
going to end you have to run them
well you know i believe that truth will
save the world
i believe that
so you speak truthfully
and you watch what happens and you take
your consequences
you know and maybe you hope and have
some faith that
in the final analysis
things will work out in your favor but
perhaps they will and perhaps they won't
but
that's faith they that's faith it's
faith isn't believing in things you
regard as ridiculous
sacrificing your intellect
it's
a decision you know
will truth beauty and love save the
world
well you could find out
thank you doesn't seem to quite cut it
for the impact you've had even on me and
also for giving me your time i know you
understand the tremendous value of time
i've i've seen it so much in your work
so
i'm going to say thank you but i'm also
going to make a commitment to do
something which i think is more
important which is just to be truthful
and i think with the platform i have in
the years i have ahead of me maybe
that's the greatest good that i can do
to the world so because you've come here
that's a pledge and a commitment i want
to make to you as my highest form of
thanks that i can give in a karmic way
hopefully that will make the world a
better place for for everybody well at
least it will
help
ensure that you won't make the world
worse place
thank you so
much thank you for everything thank you
much appreciated thank you thank you so
much
are you looking to make a sustainable
switch in your life as some of you will
know i'm on a bit of a sustainability
journey at the moment which means me and
my team are always thinking about ways
that we can make what we do here as a
business but also our individual lives
more sustainable and more
environmentally conscious and that's
where a brand like my energy comes in
they are the industry leader in the
sustainable energy industry in our
country and one of my favorite products
from my energy is called
the zappy which i have in my hands here
it's simply an ev charger which allows
you to charge your electric vehicle from
solar or wind power meaning that it's
super user-friendly while saving you
both time and money if you want to check
them out and i suggest that you do head
to myenergy.com to find out more
[Music]
you